In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 19th, on which we commemorate our righteous father,
Diyus.
On the 19th of the month we celebrate the memory of our venerable father, Diyus.
Our venerable father, Diyus, was from Antioch, where he lived for many years in Askees and
virtuous works.
After a divine revelation, he went to Constantinople, to found a monastery there.
Arriving at the place chosen by God, he set to clearing it and planted his staff, which
immediately took root and became a great tree bearing wonderful fruit.
Per Theldosios, the younger, in the years 408 through 450, visited the saint and greatly
edified by his virtue and wisdom, gave him a large sum of money for the building of a vast
monastery, which took second place among the monasteries of the capital after that of
Saint Del Matus.
Next by the Holy Patriarch, Atticus, to receive ordination to the priesthood, Saint Diyus became
a minister of the grace of God, not only in the celebration of the sacraments, but also
in the working of many miracles.
He thus, following Moses' example, caused a spring to gush forth from dry ground, to serve
the needs of his community, and also raised a man who, not believing in the miracle, had
drowned himself there.
Having come to the end of his struggles, bedridden and hardly breathing with those around his
bed, among whom were the patriarchs, Atticus, and Alexander of Antioch, already making tearful
preparations for his funeral, the blessed man suddenly got up, as though awaking from sleep,
and told them that God had given him another fifteen years of life.
He therefore went on giving joy and spiritual help to his disciples, and, once this period
of time had passed, peacefully gave his soul into God's hands, between the years of 425 and
430.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.